revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 y me acompaña como toda
nuestra mañana hace rosa pérez más de
euros a bienvenida a hoy martes vamos a
abrir revista de prensa con los últimos
acontecimientos ocurridos en irak según
lo reporta el medio al yazira recordemos
entonces que hace ya varias semanas pues
están estos enfrentamientos entre grupos
afines a irán y también los partidarios
del clérigo chiita al sadar no ellos
están combatiendo alguna manera
enfrentándose en la zona fortificada la
zona verde de bagdad y pues ya al ver
todo esta escena de caos pues también
como lo reportamos en el noticiero al
sadar le pidió a sus seguidores que se
retiraran de esta zona ya lo están
haciendo como para bajar un poco las
tensiones rosas efectivamente buenos
días raúl y precisamente los artículos
que hemos seleccionado hacen referencia
a lo que ha ocurrido a lo largo de esta
pasada noche en que según lo describe al
yazira han tenido lugar los combates más
intensos que ha visto la capital iraquí
en mucho tiempo y esto a pesar del
decreto de toque de queda que primero
las autoridades pues aplicaron para
bagdad la capital del país y que luego
extendieron al resto del territorio bien
en todo caso si godoy lo quitaron lo
quitaron después de al sadar
efectivamente entonces para resumir
algunas digamos de los puntos que nos da
a entender al yazira es por ejemplo los
residentes de bagdad se despertaron este
martes con el sonido de disparos
intermitentes y de explosiones
provenientes de la zona verde como bien
decía esta zona fortificada donde han
tenido lugar principalmente los
enfrentamientos donde están ubicados los
edificios gubernamentales y también las
sedes de las embajadas y es que
precisamente el periodista de al yazira
desde bagdad mahmoud abdel wahed decía
que claramente esta mañana se oyó el
sistema de defensa aéreo si rama de la
embajada de eeuu claro rosa ahora que
destaca el virus de sai por otro lado
hace un repaso de lo que ha ocurrido
desde ayer recordemos dice el caos
empezó el lunes por la mañana cuando el
influyente clérigo chiita sadar anunció
que se retiraba de la política sadar que
ha visto como sus intentos de formar
gobierno han sido frustrados por sus
rivales apoyados por irán después de
salir victorioso de las elecciones de
octubre pasado ha hecho el en el anuncio
de su retirada en repetidas ocasiones
anteriores no es la primera vez no y
cita por otro lado middle east hay a
distintos de los residentes de bagdad
como marwa abdel risa abogada que se
declara desesperada y lamenta que las
personas dice sean usadas como
combustible para batallas sobre las que
no tienen control bueno una situación
que igual está digamos rosa en
desarrollo no que por supuesto vamos a
ir pues llevándole toda la información
de último minuto de lo que ocurra en
nuestras emisiones informativas pero
vamos a cambiar de tema en esta revista
de prensa y vamos con lo que ocurrió
ayer la llegada también el día domingo
de armando benedetti el nuevo embajador
de colombia en venezuela se reanudan así
entonces todas estas relaciones
diplomáticas tan esperadas también por
los ganó sobre todo que viven tanto en
colombia como en venezuela rosa que dice
el país de españa en su editorial pues
lo titula nueva etapa entre colombia y
venezuela y como bien avanzaba señala
que es una de las políticas más
esperadas más esperadas desde que petro
ganó las elecciones y asumió el poder no
y dice el nombramiento de un cercano
colaborador de petro como embajador en
caracas como decías el ex congresista
armando benedetti demuestra el interés
del presidente colombiano en la agenda
bilateral no entre colombia y venezuela
sin embargo dice este paso no debe
suponer un cheque en blanco a maduro ni
mucho menos una validación de las
violaciones de los derechos humanos y
entre otras cosas este editorial señala
que pues la voluntad política de
resolver este conflicto fronterizo debe
respetar el derecho al asilo y al
refugio en una señal digamos de que
colombiano debe extraditar opositores
políticos venezolanos no y dice no es
suficiente con deshacer la política de
confrontación
establecida por iván duque pues en
connivencia con la administración nada
trump incluso sobre esto rosa con
pequeño comentario también deseado
cabello dijo que los refugiados deberían
ser devueltos a venezuela el presidente
gustavo petro dijo que no lo iba a hacer
que pues en colombia respetaba este
derecho al refugio igual en todo caso
esperemos que se abran las fronteras
pues lo más pronto posible recuerdo que
todavía siguen cerradas y que no hay
fecha de momento es una de las cosas que
señala este editorial claro hay fecha
todavía concreta para pues reabrir este
paso y los vuelos directos además otra
consecuencia que también está bloqueada
que pues también bogotá y caracas vamos
a ver cuando se reanudan pero vamos a
seguir en colombia porque el tiempo el
periódico de este país dedica su portada
a lo que ocurre en europa rosa
efectivamente no encontramos la mirada
hacia el otro lado del atlántico en este
caso y básicamente se fija en la crisis
energética que previsiblemente europa
afrontará este invierno en el hemisferio
norte como consecuencia sobre todo de la
reducción de la suministro de gas a ruso
como respuesta a la y sanciones
impuestas por bruselas contra moscú por
la invasión rusa de ucrania recordamos
el tiempo señala que von der leyen
considera esta reducción del suministro
un chantaje de guerra pero por otro lado
pues las sanciones también podrían ser
calificadas de lo mismo en todo caso
este editorial que se llama
cortocircuito europeo señala que la
dependencia de la energía europea de
rusia tiene al continente en un alto
riesgo de agitación social que en casi
todos los países del bloque los precios
de la energía se han multiplicado por 10
prácticamente en un año y dice que la
región de américa latina y el caribe
tiene que tomar nota de la situación
porque está atravesando europa entre
otras cosas entender que la transición
energética no se hace de la noche a la
mañana y que requiere de importantes
inversiones rosa como siempre gracias
por radio lista de prensa del día de
mañana con más por supuesto pasamos a
saludar a nuestro primer invitado el día